Film Courage: So you say that the B.M.O.C.
You say the B stands for one time marker,
M another, O another and on.
Peter Russell, screenwriter/script doctor/instructor:
Yes, 30, 60, 90, 110 page in a script (a movie
script).
Film Courage: Okay to play the devil’s advocate
here.
We sometimes see these comments (usually they
come in late at night) which are "This is
why Hollywood writes formulaic crap."
Peter: Yes!
Film Courage: How do we contend that?
How do we say “Well, maybe Hollywood is
not for you.”
But what would be your answer to someone?
Peter: Take a show that I would think would
be the new Robert Altman who is a guy named
Glover.
He’s a guy that is writing a show right
now that is called ATLANTA.
Now ATLANTA is now the hippest half-hour show
on television.
Glover is an African-American dude.
He’s been an actor in several big shows
but now he’s got his own show.
This guy gives us a world that we’ve never
seen before which is the world of middle…kind
of lower middle-class African American Atlanta.
Now Atlanta is a cool city.
And there is a big African American culture
that is part of Atlanta.
I would say say to you, you probably don’t
know too much about that world, right?
Film Courage: I don’t.
Peter: I certainly don’t either.
He shows you and that’s one of the great
things there are nine questions that I ask
you when I’m working on a television show.
And one of them is “Are you showing me a
world I haven’t seen before, because I don’t
want to see New York again on the Upper East
Side?
Please!”
Right?
Show me a new world.
So this is the world of middle and lower middle-class
Atlanta and it’s very (African American
Atlanta) and it’s very specific and the
story feels very loose.
And if you go and look at the pilot of Atlanta
and it doesn’t look like it’s about much,
it’s sort of like a Robert Altman movie.
It’s got a very loose feel to it.
It feels very improvisational.
It feels like there are no rules at all in
this story.
It’s got every rules, every structure, every
storyline every rhythm of HOW I MEET YOUR
MOTHER, the most commercial, sit-comey structure
that you’d ever want or you’d ever not
want or if you’re a hipster you’d say
“I don’t want to write that, right?”
It follows all the rules, so why is it so
cool.
Because it takes those rules and it shows
you stuff you’ve never seen.
The reason people say “Ahhh!
Hollywood is so formulaic is because they
are looking at band, unimaginative stories
with characters you’ve seen a thousand times,
which situations you’ve been in a thousands
times, in a world you’ve seen a thousand
times.
But the structure (the commercial structure)
is there because it’s beautiful, the bones
are beautiful.
You can take other bones out, put other bones
in, but there’s an appeal below the surface
of beauty.
If you look at what we consider beauty if
you took a skeleton, you’d see that there
is a conformity to the bones.
Now you can put whatever you want on that
bone structure.
You can make the person Tunisian, you can
make them Indian, you can make them American
Indian, you can make them whatever you want.
But the bones below that determine whether
or not they are beautiful.
I think structure of story is like the bones
beneath the face.
It’s what we’re instructively drawn to
as human beings and that doesn’t change.
But what changes, what makes things unique
is are these characters we haven’t seen
before.
Is this guy have a wound we have’t seen
before?
Glover (in Atlanta) gives us a guy (a real
smart guy) who went to Princeton but he failed
because he’s got a core wound that he’s
a loser.
And he’s come back, he’s just bumping
around and hanging out in this middle-class
(lower middle-class) world of African American
Atlanta but he’s a loser.
He left Princeton probably because he felt
like these people aren’t like me (which
I felt.
I went to an Ivy League school and I felt
the same thing) and because I’m a loser
I’m going to drop out and I’m going to
go back home.
Now back in Atlanta he gets involved with
his cousin who is a hip hop artist (who he
shouldn’t get involved with).
He also already has a baby (Glover does) and
he’s not being a really good father but
he’s trying.
He’s not being a good father, he’s not
being a good husband at all.
So all the things, all of the elements that
we’ve seen from a dozen sitcoms 1960 on,
are all present in Atlanta.
But because we’ve never seen this world
before.
So he’s kind of a slacker (an African American
slacker) and it’s also very funny.
So every commercial cliche of structure is
in this story and yet it’s the freshest
thing on television.
And so that’s my argument against not using
structure.
Think of it this way, in California we have
these vanity license plates, right?
And in a vanity license plate I think you
get even letters and in that seven letters
and in that seven letters you’ve got to
be witty.
You can’t go “Oh man you know what it’s
so cliche to have seven letters.
My vanity plate is going to have 32.
Because if you make the vanity plate 32 characters
long, it’s not going to be funny if you
have a seven letter word that says, let’s
say you’re driving a Corvette and your seven
letters are “2 Inches.”
Right?
That’s funny.
Film Courage: Yes.
Got me to laugh!
Peter: If it was a 42 letter plate plate it
would go “Hey, I drive a Vette because I
have a small pen**.
Is that funny?
No!
Film Courage: No, not as much.
The form is too big.
So commercial form is what we delight in.
The limitations of commercial form produce
the entertainment, right?
The fact that it’s a half hour means you
must cram certain things in it.
And the delight of the audience in a commercial
art form is How are they going to cram something
we’ve never heard about and is witty into
this limited commercial form.
That’s what commercial art does.
That’s why it’s commercial art.
If you want to make a sitcom that doesn’t
follow the rules, great.
Make one that is four hours long.
You can do it but it’s not commercial art
and your audience will probably be very limited
unless you are such a super genius you are
going to create a new art form (that’s what
Suzy is going to do).
Please, let’s see it from you but you are
going to have to be greater than Shakespeare
who buy the way used a three-act structure,
okay?
Shakespeare worked inside a commercial structure,
the structure of Stratford on Avon.
He worked inside that structure.
His plays were inside a commercial structure
and yet they are the greatest plays in history.
So you can be original and be commercial,
too.
That’s my seductive message for the whorish
Hollywood that there is a Hollywood pimp telling
you “C’mon baby.
Get into the Seraglio.
Do it our way.
You can still be original.”